bonsoir bonsoir ça va bonsoir alors je
vous reçois après brad pitt et matt
damon et je me demande qui reste à
hollywood parce que tous les toutes les
stars sont en france vous avez pas peur
de faire cambrioler la ba pense vous
n'êtes pas là n'ont rien a voulu tout
ceci me l a relevé à votre votre mère
est française vous parler français vous
allez parler mais c'est un tout petit
incident bien c'est bien là déjà
angelina votre mère est française vous
parler français et non j'apprends
j'apprends le français
il ya un petit chien oui dommage
vous êtes ici pour alexandre d'oliver
stone avec vous angelina jolie colline
farrell val kilmer jared leto anthony
hopkins christopher plummer et ça sort
le 5 janvier 2005 voilà alors le pitch
basset est un péplum psychologique qui
raconte comment le jeune roi de
macédoine alexandre a changé la face du
monde par ses conquêtes tollé mais a dit
en parlant d' alexandre ces échecs sont
plus grands que les réussites de la
plupart des hommes à côté de la chose
c'est que ils voulaient tous il voulait
un monde je crois un monde avec un roi
bien sûr que c'est lui mais il faut
comprendre qu'il a apporté la paix aussi
parce qu'on se battre il y la personne
battait sauf contre lui alors il a
organisé une société mondiale et après
qu'il est mort c'était riche et ça lui
plaît plus riches et finalement ça
devenu le prototype pour l' empire roman
alors le film commence convoi alexandre
qui agonise sur son lit de mort à
babylone à l'âge de 33 ans
flash-back enfance d'alexandre dont la
mère et angelina vous jouez le rôle de
la merde
deux collines farrell d'alexandre et ont
dit qu'elles se seraient unis à zeus
sous la forme d'un serpent pour enfanter
alexandre et alexandre serait un
demi-dieu d'une certaine façon c'est ce
qu'elle voyait en fait quand on se
penche sur sa vie en fait elles avaient
toutes les raisons de croire qu'il était
vraiment quelqu'un de particulier
en fait elle le pratiquer les rites de
dionysos et c'était intéressant de voir
quelles épaules en fait c'était une
femme qui comprenait pas vraiment toute
cette histoire de reproduction soit à
penser à zeus elle croyait que tout cela
avait à voir avec la reproduction
précisément donc alexandre sera un demi
dieu
alors ensuite on assistait l'éducation
d'alexandre et son précepteur vente les
contacts physiques entre hommes c'est à
dire qu'en fait alexandre aime les
hommes adorent les mecs aimer les gens
aient envie de culture il me la
philosophie les mais la littérature il
aimait l'art il aimait le théâtre la
musique était toujours entouré les
acteurs de musiciens il aimait les
hommes et les femmes
ça fait partie de la culture ça faisait
partie de la culture l'époque les hommes
à les coucher ensemble c'est tout à fait
normal et donc alexandre effectivement
était quelqu'un qui aimait tant les
hommes que les femmes
alors voilà le film raconte l'assassinât
de son père la montée du trône à l'âge
de 20 ans et puis les conquêtes l'asie
mineure l'egypte quand ils fondent
alexandrie il ya les normes bataille
d'égos gamelle
cinquante mille soldats d'alexandre
contre cinq cent mille soldats du roi
darius de perse très belle bataille un
brave oliver avait très bien réalisé
l'arrêt nadia et puis après ils arrivent
à babylone et là il devient extrêmement
dictatorial
et dépravé 1 il épouse une métisse et
leur après donc y poursuivre jusque
jusqu en main jusqu'aux granges et là il
ya une bataille contre des éléphants il
n'avait jamais vu défendre leur vie les
soldats s'arrêtent ils vont aux indes
ils ont assez on veut rentrer dit non
alors il tue et qui avec raison
il y tue 13,2 les meetings mais multi
mais après ça il va dans la bataille et
les hommes ne suit pas et c'était une
vraie histoire
ah lexandre été terriblement blessé aux
impasses il a eu une tâche dans le le
pool mon ya son cheval bucéphale qui
meurent aussi et voilà vous connaissiez
l'histoire d'alexandre avant de tourner
le film angelina est ce que tout le
monde c'est à dire tout ce qu'il a fait
alors qu'il était jeune qu'il était
vraiment uniques 1 c'était remarquable
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup
appris en faisant ce film est un jeu
j'en sais beaucoup maintenant et vous
j'ai cru qu'ils étaient russes au départ
est s'arrêterait pas de choses sur ta
vie tu le connais c'est un personnage
d'antiquités qui s'appelait alexandre le
grand et qui effectivement conquis 95%
d'un monde moderne nous aurons à
l'époque il ya eu beaucoup de recherches
faites sur lui et des milliers de livres
des millions de pages écrites sur lui
c'était des grands page de l'histoire
qui ont été écrites sur ce personnage
tous ces livres vous donne mon idée
qu'il a été vu des émotions la
linguistique au logement
il compte plus de qu'il était comme un
homme calme ils étaient être en nature
j'ai dit et écrivain il a beaucoup fait
vous dit oliver stone alexandre m'a fait
croire aux héros est ce que vous pensez
que c'est le plus grand héros de tous
les temps on peut pas faire campagne
on peut seulement dire que là l'exemple
c'est un homme le original
unique il n'y a pas eu un homme comme ça
dans tous l'histoire napoléon julia 6e
ils ont manqué s'ils ont tous admirent
est grande
chrome chrome et personne a doublé son
heureuse son record de jamais perdu 20 à
éloigner tous ces batailles même en se
sacrifiant dont le presque le dernier il
ait jamais été battu titre dans la vie
combien de fois on est battu tout le
monde croit mais il est extra ti
stratégiques qu'il était génie mais en
même temps il était malin parce que
quand il prend un pays il n'était pas
predator est inclus il fait des vagues
l'inclusion cité par exemple l'amérique
en irak a coupé larmes irakien carrément
un gel fera jamais quelque chose comme
celui de rémy de son côté il était très
malin et toujours des alliances il
faisait pas ce qu'il voulait faire un
empire du monde entier sans frontières
pense à ça c'est impossible maintenant
mais pense un idée originale alors
alexandre le vent des rois du monde à 25
ans il pouvait avoir tout l'amour qu'il
voulait tout l'argent qu'ils voulaient
et malgré tout c'est quelqu'un d'assez
solitaire non et vous m'en garde y
opposant les verts oui effectivement ce
que j'ai appris plusieurs reprises par
nos conseillers militaires c'est que en
étant leader vont s'isoler et avec
alexandre il ya cette idée effectivement
qu'il faut être seul pour être un leader
et war il est devenu l'un des hommes les
plus puissants du monde c'est également
l'un des plus seul battre pour retrouver
l'amour il a dû répondre à ces questions
de test
tout ça est un prix énorme et le prix de
2 c de tous ses succès ça a été la
solitude oui ça c'est clair
quand on est une star d'hollywood est ce
qu'on est solitaire aussi
sinon ça fait aussi que six ans que chez
moi je notais là un autre pouvait
traduire ce qu'il a dit là qui dit pas
sale
non mais c'est vrai que les télés et les
grandes stars sont les grandes stars
sont très solitaire un peu comme
alexandre moi je m'entoure de gens à
écrire en plus c'est vrai il ya
tellement de gens qui se sont sentis
seuls alors qu'ils étaient entourés
d'une vingtaine de personnes tout
simplement parce que parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas thébaux gens amis direct
avec lesquels il avait pourrait relation
autour de camp et file chez son amant
est mort oui alex endemol huit mois plus
tard
oui parce que j'avais c'était le seul
qui les met son corps a été cassé un sur
wii alors évidemment on vous dit que
vous êtes bien entouré vous n'êtes pas
seuls on vous a prêté colin farrell des
liaisons avec les plus belles stars
d'hollywood
j'ai dit que j'ai dit quelque chose
qu'il est bon j'ai dit quelque chose il
fallait pas dire
non je ne vous dis polio l'exil
milla jovovich ah oui on vous a prêté
des liaisons avec les plus grandes stars
d'hollywood des mi-mouche britney spears
et même angelina jolie est ce que ces
adresses web avec angelina ccc vrai
colline
certainement j'aimerais bien parce que
je sais que vous dites que vous n'avez
pas eu d'histoire sérieuse depuis cinq
ans mais vous prenez très au sérieux
votre votre rôle de père maintenant ça
c'est pas vraiment le genre de rôle
qu'on peut prendre à la légère
donc mon gentil petit garçon angelina
vous aussi votre fils arrive en tête de
vos préoccupations non celui-ci avec moi
mais là maddock cela
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui votre fils c'est
votre préoccupation première non c'est
la chose la plus importante pour vous
rires ah ouais absolument c'est sur wii
vous dites dans alexandre j'aurais du
mal à jouer le rôle de la mère
d'alexandre si j'étais pas devenue la
maman de maddox
je crois vraiment c'est vraiment une
mère et c'est vraiment ce qu'elle sait
qu'une aire je crois que le fait d'être
parent eh bien on peut pas l'imaginer
intellectuellement il faut en fait
ressentir les choses c'est impossible de
prétendre entre parents dont je connais
très bien les choses oui c'est pour ça
que mon rôle était possible alors c'est
parce que vous vous concentrer sur votre
enfant que vous avez pu vous dites
uniquement des amants de passage
maintenant que j'avais plus envie
d'avoir une histoire qui dure avec un
homme parce que maintenant votre homme
c'est votre fils est mon fils oui je
n'ai qu'un seul amour voilà c'est ça
c'est comme ma femme avec son fils alors
[Musique]
quand vous parlez de vos âmes angelina
vous dites en ce moment j'en ai deux
ce sont deux hommes merveilleux je passe
du bon temps avec eux et j'espère qu'il
s'amuse aussi avec moi mais c'est juste
for fun i just for fun plaisir
en fait c'est vraiment une relation
entre deux adultes pas mariés deux
adultes qui étaient ici d'avoir une
telle relation c'est qu'elles sont très
bons amis oui on en a vraiment des
bonnes relations sexuelles elle tend le
cache cache t hawk et ouais vous avait
démenti toute relation avec brad pitt
parce que vous avez dit j'ai assez de
manger pas besoin de brad
je sors pas avec des hommes mariés vous
faites pas les hommes mariés mais c'est
vraiment quelqu'un de super oui vous
avez tourné un film avec lui vous venez
de tourner un film qui s'appelle mr and
mrs smith et vous avez déclaré après le
tournage du film brad pitt est un grand
du baiser il fait ça très bien
billy bob thornton en l'an 2000 vous
vous êtes fait tatouer son nom sur le
bras
1 le tattoo isna m et comme vous avait
divorcé en 2003 vous avez fait enlever
au laser
ja oui alors aujourd'hui vous allez me
dire si c'est vrai aujourd'hui
vous avez écrit à la base de la nuque
ici je sais pas si c'est vrai je trouve
ça tellement extraordinaire qu honnête
et droit en lettres gothiques c'est vrai
et c'est tout oui mais pourquoi vous
avez écrit ça angelina j'ai commencé à
apprendre des choses sur la politique
des droits de l'homme ce qui se passe
dans le monde et je crois que c'est
vraiment la chose la plus importante
pour nous de savoir il faut qu'on ne
sache il faut qu'on en dise aux autres
il faut que tout le monde se bat pour ça
alors qu'ils avaient sur le soleil sur
l'épaule gauche
bleichroeder sur l'épaule gauche avait
cinq lignes de textes bouddhistes c'est
vrai ça dit quoi
qu'est ce qu'il a dit c'est vraiment
bien pour la france peut protéger votre
famille votre pays votre culture etc
d'accord vous avez des tatouages vous
collez non non à tous les héros tatouage
dans le magazine the lights for you and
i know this one east ohio de zuani
soyaux on le magazine allure en novembre
à léon mba vous avait confessé être
intéressé par le sadomasochisme asm vous
dites jeunes et pourquoi est ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire mais qu'est ce que vous
avez nous on a foi ici ça tombe bien et
vous avez dit j'aime repousser mes
limites émotionnel et sexuelle
je n'ai jamais été attaché mais je sens
que la personne à qui je laisserais
faire ça sera la bonne
je pense que j'adorerais ça oui
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire une chose vous appelez
angelina jolie mais vous auriez dû vous
appelez angélina super rebelle
vous voulez vous adoptez vous voulez
m'adapter non
[Musique]
et de sept merci à copenhague
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus